Dating back to the dawn of Modern English,
the expression “beside myself” has been
used to denote someone not in his right mind.
After William conquered England in 1066, French
became the language of scholars, clergy and
nobility in Britain and remained so even throughout
much of the grinding 100 Years War between
England and France (1337-1450s).
However, by the end of that conflict, the
English were pretty much done with anything
French.
During the Middle English period (around 1100-1500),
books were rare, having to be hand-copied,
and were mostly written in French or Latin.
As the English became more embittered with
the French, a desire arose among the British
to establish the language of the common people,
English, as that of the entire country.
One effort to accomplish this was to print
books in English, not only for the students
and dons at its premier universities Oxford
and Cambridge, but for the general populace
as well.
In 1476, William Caxton (1422-1492), who learned
the art of printing in Cologne, France, while
translating The Recuyell of the Histories
of Troye from French to English, established
the first English printing press at Westminster.
Cornering the burgeoning book market, he immediately
began to print original English works (i.e.,
The Canterbury Tales), as well as translations
(often from French editions).
Notably, in 1490, he translated the Aeneid
from a French version, Eneydos.
In the work, dedicated to King Henry VII’s
son, Arthur, Caxton translates the French
phrase, “hors de soi” (meaning “outside
herself”) to “mad & beside herself”
(with regard to Dido’s mental state when
she learned of Aeneas’ departure), marking
the first time the expression is used in print.[1]
Note that the substitute of “beside” for
“outside” was perfectly appropriate since,
at that time (although today obsolete), “outside”
was one of the well-used meanings of “beside,”
having first been recorded in the English
Wycliffte Sermons in the 1370s.
In any event, between the Eneydos, the Canterbury
Tales and Le Morte d’Arthur, as well as
100 or so other books, Caxton’s efforts
at bringing English to England helped standardize
its spelling and ushered in the Modern English
era (1500 – present).